um
uh
overseas
oh
um
is
[Music]
meetings
uh i do think
[Music]
good evening
everyone thank you for attending this
community input session regarding
redistricting
you should know that this is the video
and audio recorded and it's being live
streamed
the video and audio recording will be
placed online at the
general court website where it will be
publicly available and this is not a
typical meeting of the house or senate
committee and that not all members of
the committee are present for doing this
as a joint meeting this is a meeting of
the general court of the state of new
hampshire and accordingly i'd like to
start with the pledge of allegiance if
america us the superior honor for which
it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
thank you again for coming my name is
barbara griffin i'm a state
representative from here in goffstown
we are here with house members and
senator gray is here with
members of the senate redistricting
committee
i'd like to start by asking my house
members to identify themselves and then
we'll go to senator gray for
introductions of the senate members that
are here today
thank you madam chairman
my name is wayne mcdonald i represent
rockingham county district five which is
the town of londonderry
in addition to serving on this committee
i also serve on the election law
committee as vice chairman
good evening my name is marcus smith i
represent
durham and madbury in the legislature
i serve on the house judiciary committee
in addition to serving on this special
redistricting committee
hi uh i'm bob nguyen i uh state
representative representative windham
i'm on the
house finance committee as well as this
special
redistricting evening one turquoise i
represent stratfor district 4 which is
the town of barrington
i'm a senior advisor in the house of
majority office in addition to this
committee i serve on finance and the
labor
good evening thank you for having us
here um
my name is lucy webber i represent
cheshire district 1 which is the
southern most connecticut river towns of
local licensed successive buildings and
sale
and um
i serve on the house health cleaning
services
there's too many initiatives
thank you
thank you my name is paul bergeron i
represent hillsborough county uh
district 29 which is national ward 2 and
in addition to serving on this video i
election my name is israel diedra i uh
represent manchester ward 2 in the house
on the
state federal
and i also serve on the same committees
i'm a state representative ross berry i
represent hillsborough 44
which is south manchester awards 889 and
the town of litchfield
i serve on the house election law
committee
uh maybe
first thing i'd like to
recognize former senator
who is here
i don't see any other current or former
senators here
i am james gray i am the chair of the
block committee on redistricting i'm
also the chair
of the election law committee
just one thing before i pass the fight
to the other senators to introduce
themselves
uh senate rules don't
allow you to press your
cheering tapping
booming and all that if you want to
express something about it get up come
to the microphone
that's what this hearing is all about
let you express your opinions
thank you
my name is uh regina bertzler i'm state
senator from district 19 which is the
founder of uh dairy hand state of
windham
i am chair of trump education and i also
serve on
election law vice chair and i'm also um
chair of the commission on ptsd for our
hi everyone my name is senator rebecca
perkins
i serve district 21 which is
sportsmanship
in the surrounding county i serve on the
election last day and nha natural
resources
i am state senator donna sixty i
represent senate district 18 which is
manchester towards five through nine in
the town of brookfield in whittington
hillsborough county
and i also serve on the commerce
committee the election law committee and
um i have a few introductory remarks but
i i do want to say i was a little bit
miss i was informed when i came in
tonight that
general colin powell passed away today i
was not aware of that i saw an odd
headline and somebody
expressed to me what had happened and
i'm not going to ask you to rise but if
you could ever know your assignments
thank
you're here you we're here for
redistricting
information on the redistricting process
for both the house of representatives
and the senate can be found on the
general court website
on the general court home page there are
links that will take you directly to the
senate
page for redistricting and the house
page for redistricting
once you are on that you will find a
link that allows you to email on the
house side all the house committee
members
it also has a link for a separate
website and that website has information
on the committee you'll see our minutes
you'll see what we've considered you
will see recordings
and
one of the things uh that you will see
here is where the video will link for
the video tonight
you will also see that you can submit
testimony
in regards to the bills and you can
actually look and see what other people
have submitted as testimony we're
talking maps and there's an ability to
submit maps so you can go on and look at
the various builds which apply
and actually see maps that have been
submitted some of which have been
submitted by some of the people you
might have been talking to outside of
the auditorium here tonight
um so what is redistricting
redistricting it's a process that occurs
every 10 years after the federal census
is completed the population data is used
to create districts for representation
at all levels of government here in new
hampshire our constitution says the
responsibility for the creation of those
districts is the legislative legislature
which is the in the general court the
house in the senate the districts that
are being drawn in new hampshire will be
the congressional
executive council
state senate and a state representative
there is also redistricting for county
commissioner districts and delegates to
the state party convention so when you
click on that website and look at the
submission that the editing sector will
receive
there were handouts outside tonight for
you that information gives you more
detail on hillsborough county
and uh from the house side and i'm sure
from the senate side it would be very
helpful for you to comment on things
that you might think
are important for redistricting here in
hillsborough county but you can of
course comment on any of the
redistricting that we're doing that i
just talked about the congressional
senate house
executive council
there are there was a signing sheet for
people to talk there is i have one sheet
here there is still a sheet in the back
um we will get to everybody who wants to
speak tonight
um and with that um we have a number of
people signed up so we are looking
forward to hearing your input
and i'm going to simply go through
the sheet in the order
and
um
we have a mic right here for you to
speak to we have a mobile mic over here
if you're if you don't want to walk
across and you want to come down here we
can you can pick up this mic right down
here but we have that there because we
know historically you all sit on this
side i know that i come to this
auditorium a lot and it's the door where
hennessy
[Music]
district 37
it consists of two towns
hudson and pelham
total number of voters according to the
last census is 40 000 people
those 40 000
choose on a single ballot
of 11 state representatives right now in
the two towns
from my town in pelham we have two of
those representatives who actually live
in the town of helen nine
live in hudson
and that's the way it's been for 20
years
um
the we are not asking for anything
drastic you don't need maps for this
this district we just need to cleave
these two towns that have very different
ethics
i do want to make a point that this is
not
unlike some of the maps and
jiggling that has to go on this is not a
constant
appeal
this both towns are heavily premises not
even ready
and this is not going to change the
the power in the in these state house
however we are asking
like the rest of the state
of our state reps living among us
going to the grocery stores that we see
going to churches
and getting involved in the community
and i don't think that's some reason
and we've been waiting a long time for
the street district and we have promised
last time that we would have our own
district and our smoke-filled rooms
somewhere
we ended up back together in this
okay
the fun doesn't stop there though
um is as weird as it is to have 11 state
reps on a single battle
running for the state house we have a
senator a senate district in which our
senator represents
three rockingham county towns
in one hillsville county
ours
we have a executive council
representative
who lives
unfortunately not really close to pelham
and why
that district if you look out of the map
it could be copied from the old history
books i used to teach history from
mr jerry
gerrymander we would like our senator we
would like our counselor
to be in the same county that we are in
which is hillsborough county so we're
asking for a very simple thing let's put
us back
in our own district
in the county
jessica grill
from
yes
okay
good evening um my name is jessica girl
and i currently live in my hometown of
new hampshire um to start i'd like to
thank all of you on the committee for
holding this hearing and for allowing
those very first girlfriends residents
opportunities to speak i'm proud to
appear before you today to testify in
favor of your maps in a transparent and
inclusive redescription process
as a participant in new hampshire
elections both as a voter and more
recently a volunteer i believe a free
democracy is essential to securing all
of the freedoms that we do as americans
in order to ensure our government
fulfills this great purpose every vote
must count and every all voters must be
represented here with redistricting
underway it's critical that new
hampshire's new district maps accurately
reflect the population and are free from
gerrymandering and other biases
drawing paramounts will ensure that the
people are the ones who keep the outcome
of elections not big corporations
wealthy donors forces are passed
redistricting is one of the most
significant parts of the electoral
process and new hampshire residents
deserve the chance to provide input
before the maximum
unfortunately with just three days ago
before state legislators go improve maps
we still don't know when the new map
will be made available to the public and
whether there will be opportunities for
public comment on the maps
this lack of transparency is
disappointing and only furthers division
and distress
between citizens and our elected leaders
i respectfully request the committee
numbers commit to releasing the new maps
to the public at least two weeks before
the final vote
additionally to ensure that the new maps
are drawn fairly enough the public can
be involved in the process i ask that
the committee scheduled at least four
additional appearance for residents to
review the maps ask questions and voice
their free doctor concerns
in addition to allowing public input
before the new mac survey official it's
important that any additional hearings
be made accessible to online residents
via remote access
while there are undeniable benefits to a
meeting in person physical attendance
isn't always possible for many
demonstrators whether it be due to high
risk health positions caretaking
responsibilities or work studies
for the numerous teleconferencing tools
available are at our disposal it's
easier now than ever for those who can't
attend in person to make their
coursework remotely
the use of remote participation tools
has the added benefit of ensuring future
hearings are available to all of you
them either in real time or as part of
the historical record as we're doing
with our reporting today
we might not always agree on everything
here in new hampshire i'm an atheist fan
of red sox territory so i definitely
know what that's like
however one thing i hope technology on
is the importance of very equal
representation in our government that
principle is what sets our democracy
apart what guarantees our freedom and
why we're all able to be here speaking
today
in this important moment i call on the
committee to uphold their duty to
protect our democracy and take action to
make sure that the maps are done
thank you very much
to
[Music]
um
i also uh well it's great to have remote
access on people who are at home with a
health condition um we'd like to testify
should have that opportunity so i wish
that had been
thought about
in terms of the planning but um we'll do
our best with that um
future hearings would be good to have
complete access for everybody who wants
to be here
i want to let you know that amherst was
among 74 times representing 562 866
granite staters who voted in favor of
the fair religions and processes
of the elections
without the amherst the warrant article
passed by almost a three to one margin i
expected we had not been in the worst
part of a 100 year pandemic that
countless and far higher people are sick
and tired of unfair amounts and very
negative
you ever wonder why volunteers help them
need to stand out in the snow in
december and january
to collect signatures for a town morning
article residential calling for a fair
non-partisan and transparent
distribution plus finding people be
compelled to collect significantly work
with the town explain to the press and
stand up at the town meetings to speak
that's what i actually did
finally they feel that they have no
choice the argument new hampshire
not just feel good hearings to make the
public think you are listening but truly
fair and nonpartisan go to the districts
we
but you work for us and the public is
spoken loudly and clearly about what
they want and they expect nothing less
than variability maps for the state of
new hampshire
as you begin to wrap up this public
learning process you can ensure the will
of a large number of dimensional voters
will respect their honor by doing the
following
house the district committee should set
a timetable event maps are going to be
released at least two weeks before the
maps are voted on for the public to
review
analyze this didn't happen 10 years ago
you should commit to this statement with
four additional hearings after the
national bond so any questions about
them
for those who will be affected by them
gerrymandering cannot be repeated and
then unlike tonight and the previous
time hearing spanish speakers must be
given they participate in experience
remotely
if they want to testify and make their
voices heard we have a raging pandemic
people are still dying and we need to
respect the ability for people to have
their voice heard if they have uh access
issues
but the people of amherst and many other
communities within these non-buying
resolutions have clearly said
what we urge the new hampshire general
court to carry out the redistricting in
a fair and transparent way to public
meetings
not to pay their people
military party to include communities of
also signed up to to speak is the
hello my former colleagues and
representatives and senators
i just want to thank
uh representative griffin for
acknowledging colin powell's passing i
was wondering how i was going to get
back into my remarks but he was a great
and great american
so my name is melanie levake i'm from
the act of redistricting districts for
redrawing the districts every 10 years
is meant to account for fluctuations in
our population for the purpose of
accurate representation
i am here this evening not only to ask
you as our legislative body and policy
makers to draw
but to help my fellow citizens
understand that this is not supposed to
be a political process
a very real side effect of drawing the
districts to favor one party over
another was in our educational system
i live in brookline i served on the
policy appliance co-op school court and
i grew up in nashville
and i served as a senator for district
12.
between the three towns of nashua palace
and brookline there are over 13 000
public school students
with almost 11 000 of these students
relying on the national public school
system
allison brookline has some of the top
public schools in the state
and we do value our public schools
there are just over 2 000 public school
students in the remainder of the four
pounds
within district 12.
why is it that district 12
the prevailing policies of four towns
with 2 000 students in a pocket with a
population of 15 000 people
override three towns with 13 000
students
and 95 000 people
something seems off there
when lions are drawn to give one party
an unfair advantage over the other
we only widen the divide between the
parties and have more extreme primaries
and more extreme policies
the attacks on the bedrock of our
democracy are greater now than ever
and we need to make sure that voters
know
we the people of new hampshire ought to
be very concerned
earlier this year
we heard stephen stephanie chairman of
the new hampshire republican party who
said
because we control redistricting i can
stand here today and guarantee you that
we will send a conservative republican
to washington dc
as a congressperson in 2022
that's very scary
but it's also very telling
when one political party dictates what
maps look like the people of our state
are the ones that lose
this committee must clearly demonstrate
that not to be drawn for the specific
purpose
of serving the people and not the
politicians
but with just 30 days until housing
congressional maps will be voted on by
this committee the public has no idea
when we will be able to review the maps
before the vote or if there will be any
hearing for feedback before the vote
this does not instill trust in our
process
it would also serve the public well if
committee leadership would recommend to
the speaker and senate president that we
adopt remote access for public
participation through these hearings
moving forward
giving the critical importance of the
decisions being made here for the next
decade
and the rising cost
of rising cases of kobe in all of our
communities
lastly i want to caution and remind our
citizens
that the act of redistricting requires
your input
and enjoy the maps as well as your vote
at the ballot box
voters
should pick their representatives not
the other way around
and please remember the famous words of
brady
democracy
is not something we have it is something
that we do
and my fear is that if we don't do it we
are sure to lose it
thank you
next speaking is kate
marquis
[Music]
manchester and our fortiereal district
includes work eight
nine and bishop
i've lived in manchester for 20 years
sorry that you know you're here sorry
but if you look at the population of
blitzfield it's a little over 8 000
manchester 112 000 right
operating budgets for litchfield
a little over 7 million operating budget
for manchester 156 million
uh school systems a little over 1200
kids in the litchfield school
and in manchester over 13 000 kids
thousand six hundred and ninety nine of
the idps
whereas litchfield has 238
24 million for birchfield's school
brother 102
for manchester united
um i'm not sure how the needs of
manchester or richfield
are in fact
with their representation
i just want to have you guys keep that
in mind
that
it's weird for me being in manchester
to have included a town that i actually
never go to
and i'm sure it's very lovely i just
don't go south germany to the east west
north where i go on the turnpike but
down to nashua it's just the reality of
being in a high-density location with
manchester united we just don't make it
delicious
so i'm hearing that because
there's something that seems to be
coming up with more than just me
so i hope that you guys consider that
thank you
hey thank you for the opportunity to
speak today um chairman and
representative and some senators i
appreciate your time
i understand that this undertaking
is not a simple task
uh it's very complicated but i'm here
today and i probably shouldn't be
because there will be no compromise
but the only reason i know that i'm
going to be hurt is to be here today i
can write to you i can send emails to
you
but i'm not sure that i'm heard
but i know right now that i'm heard
i would like to encourage you
to encourage your colleagues speaker
sherman packard
and the senate president morse
to think about that
to think about building a more inclusive
environment
for
all kinds of folks
those who live very remotely folks who
don't have transportation
folks who have
mobility issues and folks that have
approvally concerns i know that's not
your decision not to have to
but i do feel that you're working in
these people you're sharing your
expertise with these people and i wish
you would share that opinion uh i
certainly shared it myself with them
over the weekend uh
i want to talk about the desire for fair
maps now there's a surprise you know
i've heard over and over again i've i've
paid attention to all of the hearings
uh and i hear the same thing
over and over again
the call for fair
transparent
processes
to call for a non-partisan
action
for you to see this as an opportunity
and i'd like you to be innovative
i would like to think about doing things
maybe not the way they've always been
done
but to think about what you're hearing
tonight was some of these sounds are
feeling disenfranchised
with things that they exist right now
and you know that maybe there's a better
way
maybe there's thought getting into some
commonality within these communities
and that makes more sense when you're
putting them together and they're
sharing the voting block
uh where shares of a district with
deering
we do nothing engineering
we have no shared water supply we have
no shared emergency services no shared
school district
however here we share the school
district with hillsborough
but they're not
part of a loading block of hillsborough
so that doesn't really make a lot of
sense
where it's got 9 000 people so we have
enough people to have our own
space um but we don't
so
i'd like you to find an entertaining
idea about that
i also um
ask about the criteria
that you're using
to draw these maps
november 18th is the month from today
and i understand that that's a critical
deadline for you
and look at your website and i read
what's out there but i don't really hear
any clear outline of the criteria
that you're using
to create your maps i understand that
but that doesn't explain to me
the process
so i'm feeling like i really don't know
and there's the transparency factor
because there's a lack there of
so please
think about
the critical task that you're
undertaking
and the fact that we're going to be
living with this now for the next 10
years
i don't want you to favor one party over
another but what i do want you to favor
is fairness
democracy
is a precious thing
all we have to look is around some of
our
you know countries that don't have one
and look at what their lives are like
our democracy is a very fragile thing
it's been indented and banged around a
little bit lately and i would like to
think that we can sort of restore
a positive flavor to that and one of
those elements would be a fair
public
transparent redistricting process
i would also like
as i've also heard from many other
people
for the opportunity to see the maps
and then have another chance
to offer an opinion
or a concern
or congratulations
for what i'm seeing
so please consider
i know this is
taking a lot of your time
but due to this
immense responsibility that you're
undertaking here by this process i think
it deserves
the time
to give us another round of comment
after these maps are brought
so i would appreciate that i appreciate
what you do
i thank you for your service and i thank
thank you
[Music]
members of the house and senate special
redistricting committee
thank you for the time you are spending
and the work you are putting into these
publicly sessions
this is the first time that i have
followed the process of redistricting
so far the current process is more open
than the description i've heard of
previous years and i've mentioned this
i have participated in the marathon
citizen drawn mapping project by
submitting leah from my calendar
and doing my telephone survey of 10
pounds in hillsborough county to become
your shared services
i learned how essential it is to
consider community communities of
interests that incorporate
school districts and share services and
common issues in addition to population
the maps created by this project have
been submitted to the committee's
website
and are shown side by side with the 2010
max listing pros and cons for each
version
i encouraged members of both committees
and the public to look at these maps
i believe the mapathon maps statistics
that provide warfare representation for
voters
specifically speaking about antrim its
close ties with barrington are
significant
many residents from both towns are
employed by nevada paper months we have
a shared water and sewer department
our children attend the same middle
school
banking children participate in antrim
recreation teams and activities
even our food pantry is a combined
effort
andrew and ben and vince should also
share this place
and in new hampshire house andrew is in
district 1 with hillsboro and laser
while bennington is in district 3 with
hancock and greenfield it would make
sense to have antrim and bangkok
together with other nearby towns in the
commonwealth school district
uranus in district 2 where
[Music]
it has much more in common with
hillsboro
ontario district eight includes amtrak
and heritage along with eight other
towns extending south through linebarrow
wilson and louisville
this district should be more compact
our military senate district district 8
is also spread out and in benefit from
greater compactness
when these first listening sessions are
complete i ask that you continue to have
an open process
please explain what criteria you will
consider in addition to the mathematics
of
when your maps are gone
please release them to the cover for
review before they are finalized
and then i ask that you hold a second
round of missing sessions in each county
for your
feedback from your public
lastly have the option of your
participation in these sessions so that
interested citizens may speak before the
committees regardless of their
individual circumstances
thank you for the complex and difficult
work you are doing and for the
thank you for speaking
hello i am joe rogers of district 38 and
thank you for allowing me to speak so i
just wanted to say
that like when you guys do this work
just consider sort of where we are as a
nation
like democracy is not doing well like
you know tonight i'm thinking about
whether i'm going to come here tonight
or not i'm very skeptical whether we
actually live in a democracy like i my
own personal belief is our democracy is
failing
and it's like there's a myriad of
reasons but it's
if people are losing faith that they're
that they're being heard that their
voices made heard
and gerrymandering did not help like in
the district 38 district that i'm from
it's a mess like i'm born and raised in
new hampshire before i really got
involved like i didn't even i hadn't
so this work is super important
shouldn't be partisan it should be done
based upon
principles right it shouldn't be based
upon opinions it shouldn't be based upon
politics it should be
the goal should be to support democracy
and not tear it down thank you
thank you
also signed up is
susan
hi thank you for holding this
um
listening session and thanks for all the
which is um most
northwest town
in the hillsborough county
um
another gentleman
mentioned the warren article that they
did this year i would love to say that
hillsborough the town in hillsborough
along with maybe a dozen other towns
actually did a similar warrant article
in march of 2020 this was before cohen
so we could get signatures a little
easier um and it was also before we had
the last election
so it was totally a non-partisan vote
and overwhelmingly the town of
hillsborough
passed this warrant asking for fair
redistricting and in the at that time we
were asked also requesting a fair
registration commission which we know
[Music]
didn't quite
transpire but we were asking for a fair
register thing because we all know that
this gerrymandering exists and certainly
not just in new hampshire not just in my
own b38 but all over the country i mean
i came out of massachusetts where i was
in a district that was gerrymandered all
the way around 128
i grew up in a town in ohio that was
steering angered from up in the northern
town all the way down to the ohio river
so that we could bring in some you know
different people and i you know we've
all seen the steak maps and salamander
maps and we know that it's going on
so when the time comes through yes yes
they're fairly distributed in a
non-partisan manner and as such what
happened is the town administrator on
behalf of the select board was required
to send a letter to all our elected
representatives which included
governor sununu
our state senator senator ward and four
of our representatives uh we had two of
them day one and two from the e38
and so this this was a lot of manpower
this was a lot of work to do getting the
signatures getting this boat in the town
um at the town meeting and then the town
administrator and the psych board had to
send these letters out and i have copies
of the letters
[Music]
i think it's important for you to
realize how much manpower a woman power
went into doing this just in the little
town of hillsboro six thousand people
and we had many many more towns do it um
in 2021 and it was a lot of manpower it
was a lot of work not just the best
volunteers but also with the town and we
were representing the six thousand
residents of hillsborough say we went
through the district
and i feel like our time is a waste like
what we did we're trying to be
democratic and what democracies tell us
to do and i feel like it's gonna be a
waste of time and i think it was pleased
with you to not make our time a waste
when we were trying to get very
distracted the last signature i got
to get this on the warrants the last
signature i got was from the
neighborhood of cancer she only had a
few weeks left and she signed this
petition and i'm honored she did that
but i'm also really really angry that
it's necessary for her to do that and
for me to go get his signature and
request people to science and all the
manpower they took in
to do this i mean we shouldn't have had
to drive down here for we'll start to
ask you to do better
it should be no greater i'm not a future
expert but
i know that this day and age of
computers you can plug in every prayer
that you like and you can get whatever
you want out of these maps and i am
requesting that you plug in
allowed out
in the senate chamber of the house i
will admit sometimes with 400 members
instead of 24 it takes a little longer
to get it under control but
welcome
um
so uh i'm here tonight because i'm
concerned when i hear
a republican governor
feels the need to
uh threaten veto of maps that he says
[Music]
is
so um
[Music]
desire
him back to
what we know leadership could be
and
help him recognize that
[Music]
serve
thank you
also signed up to speak is goalie
santana
[Music]
thank you
thank you for um
for giving us
this opportunity to
share
our thoughts about
well i would like to say that
these maps
are drawn by the
by the different
and they will directly impact our
communities and our generations of
future
but we still know very little about how
maps are being done
or we will be able to see them before
and even more concerned
the u.s census members show numbers i'm
sorry
um
show that the hispanic groups are
growing and political
and community um
so it's gaining power and
i think that we need to be represented
and it is critical that the districts
are grown in a way that respects the
political rights
and shared interests of that community
that is represented by each
district
and
i would like to add
as leaders that you are
and
you have the opportunity to do this
i think it's important that you set an
example for our future generations
and
[Music]
good evening all thank you so much for
allowing us to finally speak on such an
important topic with you
and thank you to those who are here
tonight
who are out here for seeing their own
health in the middle of the pandemic to
speak
on this issue and to let their voices be
heard
ask for your full attention as i can
and respect the rest of the brazens for
the donation of the public here
my name is emily olson and i am a 26
year old resident of goffstown
like many of my friends and colleagues
my age i am weighing the benefits of
making my life and growing my family in
the state of new hampshire
contrary to the seating and action of
the new hampshire senate and house
registration committees
and the whispering announcements of the
public hearings on this issue
the effects of redistricting will last
for 10 years
affecting young new hampshire citizens
ready to start the next chapters in
their lives like me
let me be clear when i say i will not
raise a family or make a life in a place
where my voice is not respected
not heard and even crossed aside in the
name of political partisanship and the
sole focus of our representatives on
winning the next election through shady
and non-democratic practices
in order for us to have a functioning
democracy the public your constituents
need to have a voice throughout the
process
therefore i'm asking that this committee
committed to holding at least one highly
advertised public hearing with public
testimony on any maps before they have
passed
this meeting must be advertised at least
a week in advance and they must have
virtual access
while streaming these meetings on
youtube is a step in the right direction
a platform that allows for public
testimony to be given virtually
such a zoom would be much more
preferable as somebody else spoke today
they already have compromised i am a
member of the proper knights family
risking my family's life to be
here talking to you but some of you not
even able to make eye contact
criterium and the process for how the
maximum jobs must also be transparent to
the public beforehand
we the people should not have to ask for
our democratic process to be transparent
we should also not have to ask for the
redistricting process to be in line with
both the us and new hampshire
constitutions and all federal and state
laws
we demand that the redistricting respect
both the geographical and political
integrity of the boundaries
u.s servants of the people should not be
choosing your voters to generate
rather we the voters are
constitutionally bound to choose our
representatives
the state understands that
gerrymandering is a pernicious process
as house bill of 1665-2020
and 706 in 2019 to set strict criteria
public input rules and an advisory
commission for redistributing both maybe
to the governor's success only to debut
without clear maps we are not living in
a true democracy without paramount your
constituents who are supposed to who you
are supposed to serve have their needs
ignored and unmet
without their math the next 10 years
we'll see even more politicization
polarization and disenfranchising
the people are angry and i am angry that
i have to fight for such a basic right
as having my voice be heard freely and
fairly
the redistricting committee has the
power to change the current atmosphere
change the cold rough and dangerous
partisanship
i am asking you to make new hampshire a
place that i would be happy and proud of
to raise your family give back to my
community
i'm asking for you to do your job serve
us your constituents we the people
instead of partisan politics
i thank you for your time for being here
i really just mean a lot and thank you
it's happened a couple of times in the
last house staff to have you removed if
before we go on
if you want to express an opinion there
are sign up sheets and anyone who signs
up will get a chance to talk
please be respectful
you know we are conducting business
under the rules of the house and the
senate the general court needs in
concord they have we have public
hearings on bills routinely and
partnered and we thank goffstown for the
accommodation to use this we've been to
every county
um and we conduct all of these hearings
in accordance with the rules of the
house and senate and i appreciate you
all being here and
following them so thank you also signed
up to speak tonight is
um christine
marcelo
[Music]
and thank you for this opportunity
as well as a process that is inclusive
and easily
accessed by your constituents
a resident of manchester
and i also happen to be a candidate for
aldermen in workforce
i spend the last several weeks going
door-to-door as part of my campaign
efforts
along the way i've met a range of people
from those who are excited to engage
with a random person
a candidate on their doorstep and talk
about the issues that they're concerned
about
to others who aren't paying this close
attention and tend not to involve
themselves in our referral process
one resident a gentleman named
christopher
who i met back in the late summer while
candace
primarily stands out in my memory
precisely because he didn't fit into the
either category
after speaking with him for only a few
minutes
in fact he pays very close attention to
what's going on around him and has some
very big concerns yet he intentionally
chooses to disengage from our electoral
process this immediately caught my
attention and i wanted to learn
shared with me that he passed his first
vote for ronald reagan back in november
1980 and continued on as a community
voter for several decades but that in
the last few years he'd become more and
more disillusioned with the state of our
government and politics at all levels
he felt convinced that he was powerless
to change things and that his vote was
useless especially to see in municipal
levels
i stood at the end of his driveway
clipboard and phone cards in hand for
easily 30 minutes engaged in a lively
discussion i did my very best to
convince him that in fact his vote does
count and that he shouldn't give up and
opt out of our most sacred and powerful
right the right
as i walked away i had little faith that
i hadn't really gained ground but was so
grateful nonetheless that he'd been
willing to somebody come with me
flash forward to september 21st
on primary day in manchester as i held
my post outside the polls during voters
you can imagine my surprise when i saw
her super barreling toward me waiting
enthusiastically to call attention to
the fact that he in fact showed up as
well
this still makes me really happy
so why am i sharing a story of this one
single voter
because it's the christopher's of the
scene we need to keep front of mind when
considering how to approach the process
of redistricting here in around the
state
these people represent both the fragile
nature and the promise of our sacred
electoral process
he went from an active stalwart voter
to a disillusioned disengaged citizen
convinced that elected officials
prioritized politics and power over the
people they shouldn't listen to serve
for christopher had happened to the
well-timed encounter with a random
candidate in an arguably obscure
municipal primary race to convince him
to re-engage and to help restore his
faith in the system
the decisions in new orleans have
implications that span far beyond a
single driver conversation
imagine the impact a fair accessible
transparent register thing could have
for so many others out there that
christopher who may have little faith
left or trust in the system who may in
fact have rule fate or custom view the
public servants who've been elected to
carry out this system
you have the power by achieving a
process that is transparent and
accessible by all to restore the faith
of so many and hopefully like
christopher bring them back into the
conversation rather than engineer a
system that keeps them cycling
i encourage you all to remember
the individuals to be committed to serve
and to please place public service over
politics and power
voters thank you
thank you
okay okay
um i am very disappointed i'm from
goffstown i'm from hillsborough county
and i need to tell you so far for any
county hearing this has been more what i
would consider almost deliberate
reaction well this can
this like this there could be an
uprising now like a little bit of
as i said one year there we go there's
our democracy right there we show nicely
done folks republicans
by showing everybody the same response
that's how we can show respect and some
speakers certainly may cause some of us
to have more of a reaction than others
but it is difficult for everyone to come
to the microphone to express their
opinion for their statement and we ask
that the reaction be the same um and i
the senate and the house have slightly
different rules and in order to expedite
this process we are conducting these
hearings together um and i thank you for
showing respect to everybody else who
has come here tonight by responding the
same way to what they say
well
um also signed up to speak tonight
and
[Music]
but i don't want to get in trouble
um
[Music]
thank you for coming
thank you for serving as legislators
it's not a thing for
[Music]
yes
um
[Music]
those of you
here who don't see uh have access to my
list and just kind of read off the
population 224
sharing
population 352
temple
population
mason population 1382
bennington
population 1476
france's sound population
is a few more
number 10 it's dealing
next column shows
the primary district of both of these
towns
and
the fourth column is the number of
representatives
for those towns
and again for those who don't have
access to this form
windsor
shares two representatives
the same with sharon
temple
[Music]
and it stays green
hearing population 1912
as free representatives
these do not include the representatives
they have
because they are also influential
districts
if you look to the next column
you'll see the number which for ontario
district varying
and the additional number of state
the second last column
shows the total number of state rights
for those women
did they say winter the population of
i'm sorry mr hennessy that you've down
[Music]
of is
but it did not have its own
representative
it still shares
to
with hudson
and is also represented by an additional
nine
i'm not going to take up any more of
your time
but i just wanted to point out that
there's something odd here
when little windsor
224 is represented by foreign
[Music]
population of 6284
population 7
[Music]
population 109
number of
stage
3.
all right if you include the population
blitz field
the population should be 117
but yet they only had 33 reps and they
so bottom line
[Music]
it's a mess
is
interested
good evening madam chair members of the
committee thank you so much for being
here to hear us tonight um
my name is shannon chandley and i did
serve in the legislature both in the
house and in the senate and it's a treat
to see friends and former colleagues
tonight
during my time in the legislature
the drawing of fair maps was always a
priority for me fair voting maps was
something that i worked on with several
of you over the course of my time in the
legislature and as you know both the
house and senate with bipartisan
majorities past
that's why i'm here tonight that's what
i want to call your attention to
hb 706 of 2019
was an excellent bill
um there were people here who championed
it and i i am very grateful to them
um
and i just want to call your attention
to the section called redistricting
criteria
because i believe that if
you
as the committee that when we line the
maps uses that redistricting criteria as
your guiding principle we will all end
up with fair maps and we will have the
outcome that all of us desire so please
when you are considering
uh the maps that you adore
um
look at what
appears in hp 706. now some of it is
very basic and essential and that is
that we comply with the constitution of
the united states that we comply with
the constitution of the state of new
hampshire
but also that districts shall form
single boundaries and shall not be
bisected or otherwise divided by other
districts
districts shall be drawn in compact
shapes and shall avoid jagged edges and
extensions
and finally
commissioners shall consider the
integrity of communities of interest to
the extent practicable
and this is really important and you've
heard people here tonight talk about
um
how to
uh engage the
different communities and look at them
so that life is being put with life so
that when people go to vote they are
voting for the interests of the people
in those communities um
the similarities of interest including
but not limited to racial ethnic
economic social cultural geographic and
historic identities
um
i also
the next section in um
in the
bill that i'm referring to talks those
the ones i just mentioned on the jews
and then there are the demons and that
is that no
redistricting efforts should unduly
favor or disfavor a particular party nor
should it unduly favor or disfavor um
allowing people
of a particular language group or racial
group so i think that if everyone
everyone involved in the redistricting
thank you very much for your time
tonight and thank you for all of your
very hard work
good luck
thank you
hi
but i was
um even though you can submit written
testimony
that there is value to speaking
in person
both for the members of the committee
and for the people who choose to show up
and spend time
engaging in the civic process so
i would very much like to thank our
committee members and also to thank
all the folks that showed up
here tonight to be part of this process
um
so i think what we're hearing
is a very
we're hearing some very very clear
things tonight
in the testimony
and that is that people
want a fair
and non-partisan
transparent process
um they want maps that represent
all granite staters
and i'm also hearing that we'd like to
see those maps
we'd like to release before the november
18th deadline and we'd like to have an
opportunity
to comment in a public way
on the record on those maps and to have
that be done
so that everyone can participate
ideally it would be across the state
with county hearings like this
but it should definitely also include
um
remote access and remote participation
and whatever we can do
um
chair griffin to help you get that
message across to
uh speaker packard we'd be healthy and
happy to help you
um in any way if we can work with him
and with you to make that happen
um
so
i think what we've heard tonight is
people very politely
very respectfully
sharing their concerns but they're very
clear
and very consistent
and i hope that you really will listen
to what is being said here
i i participated in a lot of the
hearings
non-partisan redistricting commission
and
although people at times um who i see
here
tonight represented on this committee
uh said that they thought that there
were aspects of that that were um
did not meet the requirements of the new
hampshire constitution
um
it does
the honorable
center and champion said
it was not about the other aspects of
the bill and people seem to be in
agreement that those did lay out what
fairly discipline
can and should look like
and you all really have an opportunity
tonight to be or not tonight but in the
course of this process to be heroes of
democracy to really restore people's
faith
to heal the wounds that are dividing
this country
that's why i thought the non-partisan
independent commission is so important
but we can still achieve those same
things and those same goals
if this committee commits to
those principles and
you know you could go down in the
history books
because i know that both parties have
participated in gerrymandering in our
state and across the nation
and and you all could be the ones that
break the move
and and really make us proud in new
hampshire so thank you for the work
you're doing i know it's hard work um
and i do really appreciate all the time
and effort that you put into it
and i do look forward to seeing those
maps so as soon as you can get into us
and uh as soon as we get a chance to
comment on them and i'd love to be so
resumed uh that would be great thanks so
much
thank you
yes good
evening chairwoman griffin and members
of the committee thank you so much for
your time this evening and for um hoping
this hearing
um i don't want to repeat um much of
what has been said i had a couple of
things i did want to add
one instead of very shortly
okay
um
yes thanks
um i just wanted to say and listening to
some of the folks that have come up here
already this evening
um expressing their concern and also
their dismay
um
that i
i'm harping back to my
uh my professional life as a project
manager
and when
i would manage large
amorphous projects software projects
the way we would approach something like
that is to define the criterion upfront
to find the outcomes we were trying to
achieve from
and
um i think
concern from the public comes from the
fact that the field of that part of the
process what is being used to decide
what's important and what's not
important and how we're going to
redraw the maps so that they're an
improvement on what we have
it would be really helpful i think if
people had some idea of what was
motivating
the members of the committee
and
i know that many of us who are serving
are merely
excited community members who wanted to
be part of the process
even though it's a long and arduous
process that we go through in new
hampshire i believe that that process is
in service
to getting better outcomes to listening
to each other to figuring it out
and so
i applaud you for
sticking with it
but i did want to say that as a person
who is very uh interested in the process
and willing to give up my time to be
part of that process i was extremely
disappointed
when the fair districting
bills that passed
through the house and senate
ended up with a veto because the veto
message itself said
that unelected bureaucrats should be
drawn to maps
and i am very aware from the processes
that i've been involved in as part of
the house science technology and energy
committee
uh that new hampshire very often uses
volunteers of interest
people who are combined in terms of
having you know mixes of democrats and
republicans but also people who really
have no interest in politics and have
more of an interest in whatever that
process subject is
that is the way we do a lot of our
decision making and it it's the thing
that removes it from being political and
so i was really disappointed to see that
message because
i didn't think it was accurate
for what the intent of those goals was
so the last thing i'll say is that i
actually
have experience with the ploterial
district i ran um twice
in my hometown of paulus new hampshire
and
learned what it is to be beat bad
um and then um i was asked to run in a
flotilla material district that came
about
in 2011 which was silver district 40
paulus milford mont vernon and new
boston
and prior to that time when i first
started being aware of state politics
and being interested in running
the district in my town was hollison
brookline and hollis and brookline have
a cooperative school district for the
middle and high schools so
um it was a logical district and what it
means is that the representatives
live in those towns and they also
participate in the school meetings the
town meetings and basically the issues
of the communities
so it made really big sense
it was much harder to run
in
in districts all the way up route 13
that really didn't have any relationship
with the towns in between
and mont vernon and new boston the two
furthest towns
also make up hillsborough five so
so two of the four towns were a separate
district as well
and so i went from representing 7 600
people
uh at that at the time of that
resistance then to 8 300 today because
now i'm back in holliston because i
figured
under those circumstances but i went to
a district that had 33 000 people
so
um that's a that's a huge difference
and yet
the members of the communities that
actually shared the school district were
no longer related
and um and then the representatives
again are
working in different places and so their
attention is not always focused on the
things that the community is focused on
so that's something that i would ask you
to consider as you look at how you
conjugate
towns that go together
because
there is a logic to what you share
and i hope that that will that you will
create some outcomes based on criterion
like that
thank
[Music]
um i wanted to say thank you for having
this meeting tonight and i've had
something i want to say but also i
[Music]
tax dollars paid for
um what might end up happening if they
don't have a maps like is this we want
to stay in state house and own that home
and you know covers friends to come or
based on 2022 and 2024 so we think about
moving i'd rather stay in new hampshire
but um
[Music]
but you know
we would have in that discussion you
know who you want to stay
also my mom is somebody who's in a
high-risk scheduler but this was so
important that i'm here i did send an
email already to the committee and i was
going to read that but you already got
that and some of the stuff has already
been said
i definitely do and underscore
and then also
the woman here in the grave who did all
that work with the spreadsheets i think
webinars are like the leading women
hampshire voters open blockchain phone
calls anything set on for the numbers
i mean it's over so this is what's
important to me because you guys i think
are
you know more informed
and won't be able to draw those maps and
use that software that the gentleman
here said here you can take this and
plug in the numbers and use the software
it's not going to happen but this is
what's important to me and this is why
so when i take the time and make the
effort to vote i want my vote and every
other grand estate is both to count
i don't want my vote for any other
grandstand
to be packed cracked
or journeyed
new hampshire voters should pick their
elected officials not the other way
around
you
[Music]
are tasked with the awesome
responsibility and meeting the will of
negative voters that overwhelmingly
voted for fear
not hardest in the distancing national
process
governor sununu
is on record as stating
new hampshire's elections are the gold
i respectfully request that through a
non-pilot process the redistricting
mapping
meets that gold standard that reflects
me in the community which i vote
the will of the enhancer
people
and i thank you for your time
and for me that's what's important not
the numbers
you know not the you know community of
interest and all that stuff that i
learned in crash course or webinars
that's what's important to me that's why
good evening
my name is fred mayer i live in hudson i
work in nashville
my wife and i have been here for new
hampshire over three decades
uh
regardless of where we came from our
heart this is new hampshire we're here
for the duration
i appreciate the opportunity to speak
this evening
but this process is a little a little
unusual for me
uh i'm an attorney i have had occasion
to go up the concrete to talk about
bills affecting the landlord and
lieutenant legislation because that's
what i do
but when i do that that's why for those
committees
i've had an opportunity to to read a
bill
to come to reason conclusions about
what's good what's bad in that build
of course this evening there is no
build to leave
and more significantly there are no no
masks to review
so there's no opportunity to determine
whether what's in the map is is good or
bad whether it's something i should
advocate for
or or or real against
so consequently in the interest of
having a meaningful process
my request
is that you have a timetable
for
hearings
after maps are released
and in addition
i request that those hearings have
remote participation
i was fortunate enough
to be able to come here this evening
but there are those who are disabled
those with health concerns
those who couldn't leave work it's time
to get here by six o'clock
and for those
people
out of the interest of fairness
there should be more hearings
after maps are released
with remote
participation
thank you very much
[Music]
to be perhaps overly represented on this
community
[Music]
uh for a timetable as to when the map
should be released uh within
30 days of the house going on both
congressional maps and the house maps
and to remote participation access i
work a lot with young parents who have a
great deal of difficulty finding
affordable child care to participate in
these hearings
remote access would certainly make that
much more feasible to have their
important input especially when we look
at the impacts of education and
education funding in the state and how
efficient will be drawn
uh those folks have a very vested
interest in this process
uh and with that i think i think fred
did a pretty good job on some of the
other points
[Music]
um
i'd like to add a couple
for one thing
i think we should respect the rules that
the rules are reasonable and i think
they were tonight so
i'm kind of a public school feature from
maybe
[Music]
so i'm hoping that you'll
be able to listen to the input better
this time and
incorporate it into your decision making
um
i believe the constitution of the
state says
that
if the town has a population large
enough to have a representative we
should have a representative of our own
where is large enough that about 9 000.
so
um
i think that would be a case for a lot
of if we didn't get our own
um
i also want to see those maps um so that
then you can give
meaningful employment if you had a piece
of legislation
to work with um
[Music]
if
the districts are drawn in a way that is
unfair clearly
there will be lawsuits that takes time i
think it would save a lot of time
if the districts
were fair and reasonable
when you go
this still may be some other suggestions
if he's made a mistake therefore
[Music]
but in general i think it will save time
to
form the districts
in a way that makes sense and it's there
thank you
this gentleman was smart enough to give
you the phonetics
[Music]
i did go outside eventually i'm sitting
in here and right down with the negative
system
uh my name is phil van dieber i am from
anderson hampshire i'm currently a
junior in high school
um i'm here specifically to raise an
issue that i've faced in amherst where i
find that we are actually districted
with
venture our northern neighbor despite
most of our population being centered in
the southern half of our town
um i think that this really doesn't help
us at all it doesn't help that for
either i think that we have better
solutions to our district things such as
montgomery um who is currently
distributed with us in terms of our
cooperative school
uh and i agree with most sentiments in
here about
having
an open discussion for
the maps after they are actually
released rather than us having to speak
on something that does not yet
exist to us and has just been an idea to
us um thank you for your time and i'd
also appreciate it if you understood
that one of the constituents that are
thank you for
allowing me to speak i'm not super
comfortable um being here
but uh i did send it written testimony
but i also felt it was very important
for me to
um be brave enough to um talk to people
to you all um so i have great faith in
all of you and i have great faith in the
legislature the last two sessions they
did
um vote for a fair commission and got
shut down by the governor and um i'm
sorry about that happening but i have
great faith in all of you
i'm a former school teacher and we
civics was very important to me my last
year of teaching
our class examined as a year-round
project
why don't more americans vote
we dug deep into that um with the help
of the
civics institute that
runs teaching workshops and so forth um
but i think that the fair mapping
project is part of that
people feel that their vote is not going
to count they become disengaged and i
don't care who you're voting for i just
want everyone to be able to vote that is
eligible and i want their vote to help
um i'd love to see our
american
voting percentage go up on
big time in others um
so
um i agree with lots of things that have
been said tonight um and you have been
asked the same thing over and over and
over but one thing that i would like to
pay particular attention to
is the executive council mapping um
that's a very powerful group of five
people
and
um it's very important that the
districts are drawn so that
each party candidate republican democrat
whoever else might be on the ticket has
a fair shot of getting elected
um
so i just ask you to pay special
attention to that um
i
also work very hard to get more people
engaged in this democratic process
whether it's sending public hearings in
conquering or writing on the editor or
just just participate it's going to take
every single one of us
and i spent a lot of time
gathering and
talking with friends to try to get them
to come first to the september 30th
meeting and then and then
say hey you have more time i think i can
um and
the questions were right well i don't
know what to say i don't know what i'm
supposed to comment on and so forth so
people don't know how to give you their
input because they don't know what their
colors are so i do in fact ask that
um the draft of the maps are presented
to the public and the public has ample
time to look them over and voice their
input once the those maps are done as
well as the criteria or the data that's
used to put those stuff together
so thank you very much for your time
thank you
hello
i'll start by thanking you all for
having these listening sessions in every
county if you're all busy as it is and
taking that time has
[Music]
added more to your responsibilities but
obviously very important
this is a complicated
effort is very important and as one of
the speakers just mentioned it's hard
for
the general public to wrap their brains
around how complicated this is
um especially with the house mapping and
sticking with the code after the
um again i'm john crosman from brooklyn
new hampshire
um back in 2010 our town was eligible
for its own uh house district that
didn't receive it so i'm hoping to see
that they will receive it
this year uh increased population
of course again there are some pretty uh
complicated experiences along the long
road national area for the house
um
i got involved with the mamathon effort
that is uh
led by an open democracy
back starting in the summer time
we've had upwards of 150 people in our
room uh meetings
and
those people have represented
every region of the state
so we've had good representation in
terms of the interests and
importance that the public sees in this
as part of that effort we came up with
some communities of interest
and
endeavored to
see if we could create maps that
respected these communities of interest
and also
achieved
all the requirements of the
federal state constitutions and of
the main communities and interests that
we came up with were high school saus
public health regions regional planning
commissions
shared water and sewer
communities
uh shared police and fire services
between communities
and
there are a number of social issues like
pfas and opioid addiction
and uh
other things of that nature
um
that we were able to sort of
aggregate all together and so using a
social vulnerability index
that you might be familiar with
so that is also another
uh i wouldn't necessarily call it a
community of interest but a uh
constraint that we're
trying to respect uh our maps
um
along with the effort of creating
communities and interests
we also created a pretty complex
analysis tool to use to
take a map that we've drawn typically in
phase redistricting the
free mapping software
we can export that map pull it into this
analysis tool
and it will automatically tell us if
counties have been displayed cities have
been displayed if we split any of these
public health regions or regional
planning commissions or any of the other
clis
um so we've done this uh with the intent
of analyzing the 2010 maps to create a
baseline
create our own maps and then we'll
analyze those maps and compare how well
they do in performance to the 2010 maps
and then we're also looking forward to
analyzing whatever maps you guys uh come
and also by the way i want to point out
that this effort has been done with
utmost um
uh
priority in being completely transparent
so
how we develop the progression from the
initial list of communities of interest
to the to the five or six that we
settled on we have a
history of our meetings
how we
got to that point
this analysis tool that we've created is
in microsoft excel
it uses
only worksheet functions no visual basic
macros or anything like that so anybody
who's familiar with worksheet functions
can go in and audit our tools and see
exactly how we're doing these
calculations
um
the initial maps to be developed and i
think a bunch of them are outside right
now
um
respects all of the cois
more
so and and some for some of the clies
with a much greater magnitude
uh from the 2010 maps that we analyzed
and we did that
while yielding
at least the same uh or better
population deviation
and also competitiveness and the way we
analyze competitiveness is using 2020
election data for the specific
legislative body the map would be drawn
for
um
and on top of all that we came up with a
hillsborough map our leading contender
right now has two less violations than
the 2010 map
so we were able to
create these community communities of
interest
which give us some legitimate
guidelines to creating communities and
we were able to create maps that were
just as good or better in 2010 apps
and pretty much every regard
so it is possible i understand it's
complicated
but it is possible
um
i i also wanted to add that of course if
it wasn't implied already
we're completely at your service open
democracy and the navathon team
are
willing to sit down with any of you and
go through our maps show you how we're
analyzing them we'd love to be in
service
um
one of the things that i heard at the
last i think is the most recent house
special committee uh meeting
was that there was a possibility that
reducing the state reps to 391 would
yield
lower deviations by counting
um we started looking into that and we
agree
up to this point
there are a few additional dimensions of
that analysis that we have yet to
complete
but i would uh
really urge you
to use the flexibility
our state constitution that gives us a
range of state reps to really look at
that 391 number
um
and then lastly i just want to reiterate
it was what was mentioned earlier
um of course
uh i don't think these meetings were
scheduled originally again i'm glad that
you guys scheduled them
it would make no sense for the public to
not have the opportunity to review your
maps
um before they are locked in one way or
another
so i urge you to make
your maps available i know i know
there's a strict timeline here and it's
gonna take some time to get those maps
published
but i
i along with everyone else here would
appreciate to be able to see them and
provide comments
even not just a listening session and we
[Music]
there's every possible way to make that
happen
so thank you very much
hi
i'm betty vaughn i live in linchfield
new hampshire
and um
i put my name down before that woman
spoke
about the executive council that's
really why i hope they've done because
um
i feel like it's really important i also
want to do a little webinar because they
talked about that um
and um
it seems it's this sort of line
across the state that
causes um
you know
for people to potentially be
conservative
for us to be
more liberal which is kind of what's
happening now so that's really
my concern is um
the executive council
and also i live in the field
well
i'm a democrat so i use no matter what
happens so
um i think the reason that
the this
manchester
is to
make more manchester
you know
i don't know
i just
wanted to say that and
that's really fun
right
thank you that is the last person i have
signed up to speak is there anybody else
here who would like to come on down
express themselves
good evening and thank you for the
opportunistic
um my name is
[Music]
i'm representing music in korean
melbourne
and um
i'm honored to have the opportunity to
speak tonight
the reason that i'm speaking tonight is
because for me
the most important thing is to represent
our people
to represent who put us in the secret
that we have right now
i don't see anyone
as a republican i don't see
any of you as a democrat
i see every one of you as a human being
and the only thing that i'm asking is to
have a fair representation
for my community
and expenses last year
our latino population growth
and i would like to see
our community represented very well
especially when it comes to education
is when it comes to
mental health when it comes to
many different areas
that our communities are
underrepresented
that's the only thing i'm asking
i'm asking for fairness
i'm asking for our people to tell the
voice
and then to be honest i wish
our people can be here
placing their voices
a lot of times
we have people in our community that
thinking
30 40 years
my english is not perfect
you know english is my second language
i was born in los
almost 35 years
sometimes people make fun of me because
i have a big problem as well besides
being bilingual
but i wish our community can have a
representation
they came
i know that we have a lot of good
communicators but english is not the
person which i wish they we can help
them come and
represent our communities and someone
can get translated for them what they
have to say about
what their needs are for our communities
um
the disabled community is another part
that i keep hearing from people not just
in the local community but around the
state to be honest i spent a lot of time
i spent a lot of time
traveling around the state because for
me
i'm not just representing milford i feel
like i have to hear the voices of
everyone in the city
because in order for me to do the right
thing in order for me to represent
anyone in the state i have to travel all
over the state and listen to everyone no
matter if your democrat will become or
undeclared
so my
my concern is
that we're not given the opportunity to
the disabled community
i would love to students soon
all thanks for the people who not be
already here
and from people who have a speech
and a hearing
issue um to be able to see like um maybe
um we can have the captivation open so
they can be independently stay in
and um i just want to mostly say thank
you for all the hard work
and hard work that you're doing and like
i said you know i have a lot of respect
for all of you
and
you're never going to hear me like i do
because
[Music]
thank you so much
thank you christine
anybody else
[Music]
and i didn't know about this meeting
until today
and i am so glad that i came i want to
thank everyone who spoke
i'm so impressed by the thoughtful work
that is done and their
research and the attention that you take
to these matters
and it gives me a lot of hope i came in
very simple
but i feel much better having listened
to everyone and i would applaud every
single one of you brought up
all else well with that i'm going to
close this public input session but
before we all go tonight i
i
just want to remind people that there is
online districting i have access to all
of the redistricting information on the
house and the senate side uh you might
have heard people reference create your
districting program so there's software
out there i think somebody referenced
stays for one of them if you want to get
on it and try it it's really quite an
interesting
um exercise
to sort of actually get in there with
numbers and uh the numbers you heard
referenced tonight
were those from the census and if you
took the hand out tonight you've
actually got the number so you could put
them in for roseboro county and see what
happens when you use the program um the
committee website is open for further
comments from all of you and take a look
there for some of the maps the mapathon
project handout that some of you got is
on the website along with some of the
maps that they've done and that other
people have also submitted for
consideration
so with that i want to
wish all of you a safe journey home and